we are now proud to have reached an ad
referendum agreement with the Parliament
on the distribution of fruit and
vegetables bananas and milk in
educational establishments we all
realize that the pig meat market is very
difficult and has been for a while we
are bringing in new measures
particularly a new aids to private
storage scheme which will be effective
in the forest fourth of January 2016 in
relation to the Russian ban and pig meat
and the negotiations that was they were
mentioned during the course of the
meeting about trying to reopen
opportunities for pygmy rich Russia we
are seeking on 5th quarter cuts that is
large fats and offals to see can we make
progress we have asked the Russian
authorities to come back with proposals
of how we can actually make the pygmies
fifth quarter courts available but we
haven't got any particular communication
from them in the in the last week in
this respect and hopefully it will
comment your course I am pleased to be
able to announce to you that a very
valid and well balanced agreement has
been reached on fishing opportunities
the agreement produced by the locks a
very presidency working together with
the European Commission is important not
only for the sustainability of stocks a
but for the fisheries economy of the
relevant countries Europe has started
out in two thousand ten nine with only 5
D ACS at maximum sustainable yield and
today we are at 36 ms white X in the
North Sea the Atlantic and the Baltic
Sea we are on track in our
sustainability targets and the limits
that we said today will give us a
foundation for the coming two years we
committed to measures that will be
effective enough for sea bass in an
attempt to reverse the steep decline of
this talk our responsibility to our
citizens and to the sector is to deliver
on the objectives and ambitious of the
Common Fisheries Policy and today we
made yet another important step in that
direction